[Music]
hey everybody so surprise surprise Rick
and Morty just released like a little
promo of mr. poopy butthole and his
backstory with his wife and his family
so one Happy Thanksgiving I know
everybody's wondering when season four
is actually going to get here so I'll
try to address that at the end of this
but there are a lot of Easter eggs and
references from the adventures that Rick
and Morty have had throughout this so
because it's been a while since we've
actually had new Rick and Morty all say
there's a new round of the Zen monkey
Studios merch giveaway all you have to
do to enter that is just be a subscriber
and leave a comment on the video I
announce winners at the end of videos so
you start out with different versions of
the season to outro like where he turns
the TV off like he's been watching the
entire season so just confirming that
he's one of the few characters that
actually knows that he's inside or these
characters are inside of a TV show then
they get to the backstory so I love that
his scrapbook is the poop in my pants
and there's actually a couple of
references to the poopy butthole race
that they belong to so like you see the
ultrasound of their baby in his wife's
womb who looks like a poopy butthole
version of Jessica but the baby actually
has a top hat on it in the womb so you
can look at the logic however you want
but they can take those hats off but
they grow them in the womb so they're
like organic extensions of their bodies
so as a child he went to the same high
school as Morty did but it's from a
different reality but here's where it
gets a little nuts so during the course
of season 3 during the Beth episode you
see her stare at the fridge she has a
bunch of pictures of her family but then
you see this symbol on the fridge magnet
where Morty is and it's like is that a
evil more anything like what's going on
with that and you see that it's the same
symbol on the flag of mr. poopy
buttholes childhood highschool but in
the way that they mess with your head
during the Total Recall episode making
you think that mr. poopy butthole has
been there that whole time which reality
are we in during this episode because
you could believe that it's from a
different earth and they just borrow
this fridge magnet when they were
visiting him in a different reality the
only thing that really confirms this is
a separate reality that mr. poopy
butthole was in is when he's actually
sitting in class with his version of
Jessica falling in love and you just see
the aliens sitting with them like if
this were Morty's reality or any version
of Morty's reality that we've seen
so far they'd be normal people like they
seem like they have a Cronenberg
incident that maybe they later are cured
because they're sitting on the benches
here while they're still in school they
graduate get their GEDs as he says
during that season three post credits
scene you see that my Federation rewards
that just means that the Galactic
government is getting ready to take over
the earth the same way it did at the end
of season two they have the same
adventure kicking them off of the earth
that Rick and Morty had during the first
episode of season 3 I love that they
scrap both a piece of grumble might hear
like they literally hack a piece of it
off and put it in the scrapbook as you
slowly pan up this actually looks like
it's from later in their courtship or
their relationship but they go to the
same detoxifying facility that Rick and
Morty went to you can make all the
theories you want about which aspects of
their personalities they found toxic
because it's different for every person
but the cool thing is is that as you see
them just writing the foreground having
fun together
zum enhance in its Jaguar jumping out of
the airplane like he did during the
pickle Rick episode courtship in the
park singing songs to her while they're
being watched in the bushes by the
vampire master from the tiny Rick
episode this is where it gets a little
bit crazy because it's the exact same
scene in front of the fountain where
he's proposing to Morty from the Morty's
mind blowers episode so there were a lot
of people after that episode that were
split on what that memory meant half the
audience thought that this was him
helping mr. poopy butthole with his
proposal like just doing a little dry
run the other half thought it was
actually meant to be a literal thing
like he was literally proposing to Morty
who then accepted and Rick had to erase
his mind because he wanted no part in
that nonsense they get married by the
Jewish rabbi from the Armageddon episode
so I guess that means either mr. poopy
butthole is Jewish or his wife was and
he just converted for her they move into
the apartment which I think we can
assume is the one from the season 3
post-credits scene there are a couple
apartments that you see him in the
season two post-credits scene apartment
is a little bit smaller than the one we
see him in at the end of season 3 but
you just see them with their cat and dog
and then it goes into this montage of
them scrapbooking their dog and cat like
they're in a relationship and it runs
their full course there's even a plum
bus here in the background but then it
gets really sad the cat gets ready to
die everyone
it's grieving but within minutes of that
she comes in and says I'm pregnant like
I said probably the funniest thing about
this is the fact that he's growing the
top-hat in the womb like it's actually
an organic piece of his body the great
thing about this baby shower picture is
that you see that their culture is
toilet based so the poopy butthole name
actually has some logic to it it's not
just meant to be funny nonsense and then
most of you even if you're not big
Beyonce fans probably remember this
picture from a couple years ago when she
was pregnant for the first time she made
this like special Instagram announcement
blew up the internet for a couple days
just announcing that she and jay-z would
be having a baby baby's born he closes
the scrapbook like looks up almost like
he's thanking a higher power you can
take that however you want he's just
being thankful for all the things that
he's had because he was in a pretty bad
place at the end of season 2 remember he
was addicted to painkillers like he just
gulped down all those pills even Justin
Royal and made a joke about it seems to
be in pretty good health think he's off
the meds you got a real problem epidemic
in this country of pharmaceutical
addiction so it's good to see that he's
curbed with that issue then he just
looks at his wife and son and they get
ready to have their dinner together
it'll be interesting to see if they have
another season for post-credits tag
where they follow up with this family
and they just keep doing that for
however many seasons rickum already goes
97 more years but let me know in the
comments what your favorite background
detail from all this and I know
everybody wants to know when season 4 is
going to drop nobody has released any
new information about that other than to
say Dan Harmon revealed during a
harmontown that he basically had no cash
on hand he was almost broke so he's
waiting on payments from the episodes
that they deliver for season 4 and also
profit sharing from season 3 the deals
get a little bit complex like they get a
percentage of merchandise that they sell
and all that kind of stuff but it takes
a long time for that to be calculated
and then also there's the process of
them delivering episodes for season 4
like they have to deliver scripts first
the scripts have to be approved by the
network then they go off to animation
most of the writers on Rick and Morty
right now are on hiatus so it seems like
right now a lot of the early work on
season four is done but obviously
there's still all the animation left to
do and that's really
where you get into the big long wait so
don't look at that mr. poopy butthole
post-credits scene from season four with
the white Santa Claus beard as proof
that it's not going to come till next
Christmas
this is them having a little bit of fun
and building themselves room for margin
of error so like they don't want to say
what the data is probably going to be
and then miss that wildly and have fans
be really upset so they're like okay
it's gonna be a long ways away in
related news I do have that Rick and
Morty gravity falls Easter Egg video
I've just been waiting to post so let me
know if you guys want me to post that
but any other bonus videos you guys want
just let me know in the comments
congratulations to the giveaway winner
from my last Rick and Morty video
Alexis Gonzalez please private message
me so I can get your contact details
I'll name a new winner the next time I
post Rick and Morty so you can click
here for my season 4 videos and you can
click here for all my season 3 videos
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
[Applause]